hi it's almost time to say goodbye but
we have a little time left
for some of your questions first up is a
twitter question from camille
she asked what has your experience on
the drew barrymore show taught you so
far
wow um you would think you know only
having been on the air
a week i wouldn't know much but we've
actually been in this for
many months over a year trying to get
this show launched so
i have learned a lot and the truth is i
think that this show is inspiring me
to really be the best version of myself
that i have ever been it's what my kids
do
for me but this show just like my
friends and loved ones
they all just want to make me they make
me want to be a better person
that's that's the truth answer all right
let's get a question from our virtual
friends crystal
what do you got for me hi how are you
oh i am loving your look oh thank you
well just like you i'm a mom of three
and my adult my young adults are spread
out in the midwest
i want to know how do you balance this
fantastic career
plus your most important role being a
mom to frankie and ala
you know that's the most important
question honestly
and the truth is is that i always sort
of have an internal
clock where i know that
it's just it's been too much work and i
gotta get back to the kids and we all
feel like when we're with our kids that
we're dropping balls at work
this is a natural seesaw of parenthood
and professional life but my kids come
first and it's how i live my life and
i'm very disciplined about it
but i'll tell you this it never feels
like i'm pulling it all off
so anyone who else who beats themself up
there let's try to change that
because i am fault i am at fault of that
too thank you crystal for your question
we want to thank you and if you want to
be one of our virtual friends
come see us and get your tickets right
now at the drewberrymoreshow.com
[Music]
you